I heard that co-cutive cycles glutathione prevents apoptosis, do you agree?
It's true, my son's spectrum is co-cutive, should I stop?
Should I be taking something else?
So, you know, I don't agree and I don't agree that recycling glutathione prevents apoptosis.
Your glutathione will recycle the glutathione.
That's how you glutathione is oxidized and then reduced.
That's the recycling process of glutathione that every cell that happens in every cell.
And there isn't anything wrong with cancer patients taking glutathione.
The argument with cancer patients taking glutathione is, first of all, I don't think there's anything wrong with cancer patients taking co-cutive.
There isn't argument about cancer patients taking glutathione because they say that, oh, it'll help, you know, it helps increase the metabolic process and help heal the mitochondria of the cell.
That's why you would take glutathione.
It's a strong antioxidant.
It's the number one intracellular antioxidant.
If a person is doing chemotherapy, I would agree.
It's probably not a good idea to be doing to be doing glutathione, taking glutathione, if you're doing chemotherapy.
Same the reason why you wouldn't do antioxidants like alphalopeic acid or vitamin C while you're doing chemotherapy.
If you're done with chemotherapy or you're beyond 48 hours after chemotherapy or chemotherapy infusion, you know, there's, I don't see any harm in trying to protect your healthy cells by giving them the ability to detoxify a poison.
That's what an antioxidant does. That's what glutathione does for yourself.
That's what an antioxidant does. That's what an antioxidant does.